un mes después de las elecciones
generales este martes se reunió por
primera vez el nuevo bundestag con más
escaños de la historia
736 entre los nuevos representantes más
mujeres más jóvenes y más personas de
origen migrante que nunca sin embargo
las cifras quedan lejos de la paridad
históricamente el discurso de apertura
lo pronunciaba el representante más
longevo de la cámara sin embargo el
parlamento voto un cambio en el
reglamento para evitar que recayera en
el octogenario de la ultraderechista
alternativa por alemania alexander
gowland por lo que desde 2017 el
encargado de abrir la sesión es la
persona con más recorrido como diputado
en este caso el ex presidente de la
cámara baja el conservador de la cdu
wolfgang schauble quien también ha
escenificado el relevo de su cargo hacia
la socialdemócrata barbel bas
defiendo que en esta nueva legislatura
desarrollemos una nueva cercanía con la
ciudadanía no sólo porque este
parlamento está compuesto de un grupo
significativamente diverso debemos
llegar a mucha gente en este país sobre
todo a los que durante por mucho tiempo
no se hacen interpelados por la política
la ceremonia se ha desarrollado bajo la
mirada de angela merkel desde la tribuna
de honor por primera vez en 31 años la
mandataria conservadora no ha revalidado
su escaño desde este martes la histórica
canciller deja de ser oficialmente jefa
del ejecutivo alemán sin embargo
permanecerá en el cargo en funciones
hasta la investidura de su sucesor si
socialdemócratas ecologistas y liberales
acaban logrando un acuerdo de gobierno
el socialista olaf scholz podría ser
investido en diciembre entonces
concluirá definitivamente la era merkel